how do i deal with failure
you know failure failure sucks but if
you didn't have failure you'd never
improve you'd never change uh if if we
didn't fail in life then we you know if
we one thing i heard is that
that i liked is that if you got
everything out of life that you wanted
if you always got what you wanted you'd
probably still be living in your
hometown you'd be married to your high
school sweetheart you'd be like the
manager at your first job right so it's
important to fail because failure is
what causes us to get up and move and to
change and through change we get growth
so failure is just a path towards growth
so as long as the failure led to your
growing and improving it's not failure
it's like when i lift weights i'm
lifting weights to failure right i'm
deliberately going for failure why
because that's the point at which my
muscle will grow i don't want to injure
myself so i don't want to fail so hard
that i can't recover and i don't want to
not learn from it i don't want to fail
lifting the weight drop it and then
never come back but
you know small amounts of control
failure that you learn from is exactly
how you grow it is a part of the process
and there is no way around it and i know
that it's
it's hard to feel that way when you've
just tried for something so hard and you
fail
but it's it's just important to keep
going everybody fails all the time
[Music]
you